Now, I don't want you to feel intimidated by all of these complexity classes
rather you should be proud of yourself and I would say congratulations to you
for having learned so much in this course about computational complexity
where you met Alice, Bob, and Carol and later, we also met Dave
We didn't know anything about their problems.
We didn't know if there was a good algorithm for vertex cover or if we just couldn't find one.
Similar for clique and independent set and shortest tour.
Later, we also learned about SAT and then we started out with the concept of NP completeness,
which suggested that many of these problems here are hard.
Then we went on to search trees to show how some of these problems
nevertheless can be solve efficiently, and we introduced the concept of pre-processing.
We showed that some problems are fixed using parameter tractable
using either the size of the solution or some parameter such as distance
from triviality as a parameter.
We talked about constant factor approximation algorithms, the concept of a PTAS,
problems for which there's likely no constant factor approximation algorithm
unless P=NP.
We talked about Monte Carlo randomized algorithms.
We talked about Las Vegas randomized algorithms.
And we talked about which of these problems, although worst-case analysis
might suggest otherwise are usually very well solvable in practice.
This is my final quiz for you in this unit.
What I would like you to do is think about all the things you now know about these problems
what you know about vertex cover, what you know about clique and independent set,
about shortest tour, and 3-SAT and then just make check marks here on what you know.